the first parent and the college bribery
scandal has been sentenced and it is a
high-profile one on Friday actress
Felicity Huffman was sentenced to 14
days in federal prison and other
penalties after pleading guilty to
conspiracy to commit fraud legal
observers say Huffman sentence could be
a sign of things to come for the 51
others charged in that scandal Kenneth
Craig is here with more Kenneth good
morning good morning to you Michele
Huffman is one of dozens of parents
charged with paying mastermind Rick
singers organization to get their
children into elite universities
prosecutors looked at Huffman to make an
example out of the desperate housewife
star who pleaded guilty to fraud and
conspiracy charges back in May
actress Felicity Huffman stared straight
ahead as she left the courthouse with
her husband actor William H Macy she's
now a convicted felon in court
Huffman told the judge her voice shaking
I am deeply sorry I've inflicted more
damage than I could ever imagine she
said her daughter told her I don't know
who you are anymore prosecutors argued
she should spend 30 days in prison for
paying $15,000 to have her daughter's
SAT answers corrected a message must be
sent prosecutors argued in court an
imprisonment is the only way to send
that message the judge agreed telling
Huffman that quote being a good mother
did not excuse her actions in a
statement released after sentencing
Huffman said I accept the court's
decision today without reservations
there are no excuses or justifications
for my actions
period now that the judge has ruled on
Huffman 14 others who also pleaded
guilty will soon learn their sentences
CBS News legal analyst Ricky Clayman the
message this sentence sentence to those
who have already pleaded guilty is that
you are not walking out of this
courtroom you are getting a minimum of
14 days it's likely actress Lorie
Lachlan and her husband designer Massimo
Jia Dooley both pleaded not guilty in
the scandal the couple is accused of
paying half a million dollars to get
their daughters into the University of
Southern California by creating fake
athletic
profiles for them right now they should
be feeling very nervous because a
Felicity Huffman wasn't walking out of
there
nobody was Huffman also received one
year probation 250 hours of community
service and a 30 thousand dollar fine
she's required to self report to prison
by october 25th and her lawyers are
hoping that's in California a lot of
people watching that right now to see if
justice is sore thank you